today on the matt welsh show congress
passes a stimulus spill it's what we
expect from congress in all the worst
ways also five headlines including
another brave celebrity coming out as
the opposite sex and the left attacks
marco rubio for getting a vaccine before
other groups who need it more get it
while ignoring democrat lawmakers who of
course are doing exactly the same thing
plus our daily cancellation and much
more today on the matt wall show
[Music]
[Applause]
well here's a new year's resolution that
uh we could all think about
how about supporting companies that have
morals supporting companies that support
us in the culture
and if you want to do that then i'll
give you the first company you should be
looking at um
sponsor loyal sponsor of this show
charity mobile the pro-life phone
company
look with charity mobile five percent of
your monthly plan price goes to the
pro-life pro family charity of your
choice the new activations and eligible
accounts get a free cell phone also with
free activation and free shipping so
you're getting a great service on top of
the fact that you're supporting a
company
that is doing uh this work for the
pro-life movement also
there's no contracts there's no
termination fees you got no risk with a
30-day guarantee so
the fact is they're not trying to you
know get you
sucked into something where you can't
get out of it i'm not trying to trap you
with anything this is this is an honest
company
and that's why they're helping to build
a culture of life in america
you also get live customer safe service
based in the usa
you can you have the ability to block
the use of cellular data picture
messages
text messages on any or all of your
lines that's going to give you extra
security
it's also going to help you you know
maybe protect your kids if they have if
they have cell phones as well
you get a free app to monitor your usage
to pay your bill and much more
you can turn everyday living into
effortless giving
um with by giving to the charity of your
choice with charity mobile
nationwide service on america's largest
and most reliable 4g lte network as well
if you want all of this what you got to
do is call 1-877-474-3662 or chat with
them online
at charitymobile.com well if if one
thing has become
clear during the course of this pandemic
it's that our leaders simply don't care
at all about the well-being and welfare
of the people they're supposed to
represent and lead
and it's not that they hate us you hear
that a lot oh they they hate us no
hatred
would require a passion that they don't
possess it would mean that they
care if in the wrong way what we get
from washington instead is much more
banal
much emptier worse even
what we get is disregard indifference
neglect
and this is put it mildly not the
attitude you want from your lawmakers at
any time
and especially not at a time like this
it was easy to predict this you know in
hindsight or even in foresight um
if you have a group of people in charge
you don't really care what happens to
you or your family
and also don't really care about the law
then the pandemic hits
what are they likely to do they're not
they're not just going to leave you
leave you to your own devices which
would have certainly been preferable
but they are you know they're they
aren't going to do that because
they want to appear like they're doing
something also they realize that they're
being presented with a profound
opportunity to
seize more power and influence so
instead they
shut everything down tell you to stay
home tell your children to skip school
for a year
tell you not to visit your elderly
parents or let your children see their
friends
and then pat themselves on the back when
the numbers go down when the numbers go
up
as they have they will just blame you
for not listening to their instructions
no concern for your overall health and
well-being no concern for your quality
of life
no concern for your life at all no
concern for your child's education
none of that you're just a number a
statistic
what do they care how a statistic feels
why should they care about a number's
suffering this dynamic was thrown into
sharp relief this week with the stimulus
bill that congress
came up with in a compromise now you
always know you're in trouble whenever
there's a bipartisan compromise
people always love bipartisan
compromises i don't
it's bad enough when one party has a bad
idea but when they both agree on a bad
idea it has to be especially horrendous
and it is
the bill 5000 pages long totaling almost
a trillion dollars in spending
would among other things many many other
things which we'll get to in a minute
provide 600 checks to some americans
now some lawmakers have objected to this
portion including rand paul
who should be commended at least for
objecting at all but his objection might
miss the point
a little bit listen why stop at six
hundred dollars a person
why not a thousand dollars why not two
thousand dollars
maybe these new free money republicans
should join the
everybody gets a guaranteed income
caucus
why not twenty thousand a year for
everybody why not thirty
000 if we can print up money with
impunity
why not do it the treasury can just keep
printing the money
that is until someone points out
that the emperor has no clothes and that
the
dollar no longer has value
to so-called conservatives who are quick
to identify the socialism of democrats
if you vote for this spending montrosity
you are no better
when you vote to pass out free money you
lose your soul
and you abandon forever any semblance of
moral
or fiscal integrity now i agree that the
government spends too much and is
spending too much in this bill as always
it's a trillion dollars absurd um but
when it comes to the
direct payments to individuals there are
two ways of looking at it one
is that the federal government shouldn't
be giving anything to anybody in this
case
the states are the ones that have
imposed these lockdowns why should a
taxpayer in say north dakota
have to bail out a small business owner
in new york should new york do that it's
new york's fault
this line of thinking would lead to
congress spending zero dollars on direct
payments
the other line of thinking is that the
federal government is also
also responsible for pushing the
lockdowns especially through mouthpieces
like fauci and berks and
besides as this line of thinking would
go whoever is to blame the fact is that
millions of americans are in dire
straits through no fault of their own it
was public policy
on whatever level that brought us here
we pay congress to help solve problems
like this
now they need to do their jobs but
that's going to require a lot more than
600
for the people who need it now place the
blame wherever you want the fact is that
the government
has shut down entire industries
prevented millions of people from going
to work
bankrupted businesses thrown families
into financial ruin and destitution
the government did this if the
government tells you that you aren't
allowed to go to work or that as a
business owner you aren't allowed to
serve customers
or you could only serve you know thirty
percent of the of
of your customers the government is
taking from you and it owes you
restitution
compensation this isn't welfare this
isn't the normal sugar daddy routine
from the government this is about
americans
getting what they're actually owed
actually entitled to an entitlement in
the true sense of the word
the whole problem with what we normally
call entitlements
is precisely that the people getting
them are not entitled to them
in this case they are but the problem is
that 600
is an insult it's a slap in the face
it's worse than nothing it's the
equivalent of on a smaller scale
you know when i was delivering pizzas as
a teenager and
one time the customer was was mad that
his order was late not my fault
by the way so he paid his bill and then
pulled out a nickel
to hand it to me as a tip he meant it as
an insult
and if it was like 50 cents at least
maybe i would have taken it but even i
won't lower myself for a nickel
this is like that you know they're
tossing a nickel at the people
that they have bankrupted 600 may as
well be a nickel if you just
lost your business or about to lose your
house can't afford food
and so on if you have say four thousand
dollars of necessary monthly spending
including mortgage and food and
utilities and all that
car payment whatever 600 bucks isn't
better than nothing it is nothing it
gets you nowhere does nothing for you
and it gets worse the bill also includes
all sorts of goodies put in there by
various politicians for the sake of
their special interests
tom elliott with uh grabian media has a
good thread on this
let me read some of what he found in
this bill
and this doesn't even begin to cover it
as the thing is again 5 000 pages
long there is no good reason for a piece
of legislation to be 5 000 pages long
or even 100 pages or even 50 pages all
of those extra pages
give you stuff like this as elliott
documents quoting from his thread
says the covert relief bill lays
groundwork for a climate security
advisory council
the cover relief bill also includes 10
million dollars for
gender programs in pakistan not exactly
sure what that even is
the coveted relief bill sets aside funds
to investigate the 1908
springfield race riot the bill includes
a lengthy subsection titled the horse
racing integrity and safety act of 2020.
the bill creates a committee regulating
performance-enhancing drugs and horse
racing
the bill outlays funds to address gender
inequality amongst statues
not sure that's i think we need to read
closer into that one but this is this is
just what he's what he's come up with
the covet relief bill includes funds for
a museum that will offer
programming education exhibitions on the
life art history and culture of women
the cover relief bill includes 1.5
million for the appropriations
committee's
office of diversity and inclusion as
well as lots of money for receptions
and we could go on listing things again
5 000 pages
that's three copies of war and peace
stacked on top of each other and somehow
even more boring to read i'm sure
this is what we get our elected leaders
playing games
attending to their special interests
while millions of americans
plunge into destitution this should make
us all
there's a lot of cheap outrage out there
every day over dumb
things this is uh this is real this is
something that is really outrageous that
is really
worthy of our of our outrage i see
people
online i don't know how many i don't
know if i could trust them or not you
know i i think people are probably
exaggerating but
around this time you see people you know
posting their their reading list for the
year
oh look i i read 75 books this year
bragging about it uh i don't know if i
could trust that or not but
what i can tell you for me i i did not
read all the books i wanted to read this
year
uh my reading list is not that extensive
at all because it's just been a busy
year and you don't always have time to
read the books you want
um and uh that's unfortunate because
there's a lot of information a lot of
knowledge out there and all these books
and
even if you have all the time in the
world you still will never be able to
get to
you know to even even even crack the
surface of all the knowledge that is
there
and that's why thinker is such a great
company
um thinker one of our latest sponsors
you know in a fast-paced world
it's tough to make reading a priority at
least it used to be at thinkor.org they
summarized the key ideas from new and
noteworthy nonfiction giving you access
to an entire library of great books in
bite-sized form
you can read or or even listen to
hundreds of titles in a matter of
minutes
old classics like dale carnegie's how to
win friends and influence people
they've got recent bestsellers like
jordan peterson's 12 rules for life and
lots of books in between thinker offers
a large variety of titles across
many categories if you're looking for
politics current affairs
business education history relationships
whatever you're looking for in the
non-fiction category
they've got it and it's an opportunity
to
learn from all of these great thinkers
even if you don't have the time to sit
down and read all these books if you
want to challenge your preconceptions
expand your horizons and become a better
thinker go to thinker.org that's
t-h-i-n-k-r-dot-org to start a free
trial and download the app today
let them know you heard about them on
the matt walsh show that's thinker.org
now let's get to our five headlines
[Music]
okay so uh just saw this and
anthony fauci was on cnn
this morning and a reading article in
the hills as anthony fauci
said monday that he would not recommend
suspending flights in from the uk over a
more infectious chronovirus strain
detected in southern england the us
should fauci said
without a doubt keep an eye on it but we
don't want to overreact
follow it carefully but don't overreact
to it
now this is a they're saying a new
strain of of
covid which is at least
they think uh quite a bit more
contagious than the other than than
this the other strain um and fauci's
saying well we don't we don't want to
shut down travel let's not overreact
now here's the thing i agree with not
overreacting and that's advice
that i wish fauci had been taking i wish
he would take his own advice
and had been taking over the last seven
months yeah we shouldn't overreact
but it seems to me we should be
here here's here's fouchy's approach and
the approach of
of of many of our health experts and
people in charge
has been they're they're very reluctant
to shut down foreign travel
but not reluctant to shut down american
businesses
call me crazy i think it should be the
exact opposite
we should be extremely reluctant to shut
down american businesses to the point of
we don't do it
at all but as far as shutting down
foreign travel i don't think we should
be reluctant to do that at all
even if there isn't a pandemic if
there's any concern if there's
something going on overseas that you
want to contain shut down foreign travel
sure i don't think there should be very
much reluctance at all in that in that
uh
in that realm especially now so if
you're telling us that there's a
vastly more contagious strain of
coronavirus and it's in the uk right now
and as far as we know it hasn't made it
here yet
shut down travel why wouldn't you do
that
shut it down so that we don't end up
shutting down businesses again
or more businesses
we know how this is exactly how it
played out back in march
we have seen this movie before guys like
fouchy say oh i don't want to shut down
travel and
uh when when president trump started
shutting down travel you had democrats
complaining about it
accusing him of xenophobia
and then a few weeks later it's here and
everyone says why do you do anything to
stop it
i just i get a very bad feeling with
stories like this because i feel like
we've
we've seen this movie i feel like it's
just repeating again
i am not at all um a uh
someone who's propagating panic over
over covid but
if if they're telling us the strain is
there in the uk why not just shut down
the travel i don't see why we don't just
shut it down
next nancy pelosi on the floor of the
house yesterday
claimed once again that her opponents
are the ones who
deny science let's let's listen to this
we didn't do it we couldn't pass
legislation until now
because the administration simply did
not believe
in testing tracing treatment
wearing masks sanitation separation and
the rest
scientific approach it has come clear to
us now that they believed
in herd immunity quackery
springing right from the oval office
and not denied sufficiently by some of
the
cdc and the rest so now
we have a vaccine and that gives us hope
a vaccine that is springs from science
people say around here sometimes i'm
faith-oriented
so i don't believe in signs and i said
well you can do both
science is an answer to our prayers and
our prayers have been answered
with a vaccine and in this legislation
we had provision
for it to be that perch developed
purchased
and distributed in a way again that is
fair
and equitable and free
people say around here sometimes i'm
faith oriented so i don't believe in
science
just a quick fact check on that nobody
has ever said that
that's i guarantee you nobody has ever
said that
to uh to nancy pelosi i'm faith oriented
so i don't believe in science
of all i don't think anyone who is
faith-oriented would call themselves
faith-oriented more faith-oriented
i don't believe in that science get that
science out of here that black magic
this this is what people like nancy
pelosi this is this is what they think
of their opponents
this is the cartoon that they have
in their heads when they think about
the people on on the other side of the
ideological divide but
uh but no that is that is not something
that anyone
has actually said to her and of course
as i have documented many times if we
really want to get into who is denying
science then
you know i personally think we have to
look at the people who would say that
an unborn baby in the womb is not a
human
uh we have to look at the people who
would say that you know a man can get
pregnant i mean
that is where i think the real science
denial comes in
it's so important to always be ready to
protect yourself
and your family especially if you have a
family you want to have the ability
whatever happens to protect them and
that's why i'm so excited about
one of our newest sponsors on the show
to close out the year
taser taser's line of non-lethal
self-protection devices are small and
lightweight enough to carry with you
or in your glove compartment or your
purse um they're also powerful though
powerful enough to incapacitate an
attacker
they use an electrical charge to
immobilize attackers for up to 30
seconds
giving you time to escape to safety and
uh and uh and
this is this is also great it also sends
you know signal so that
emergency dispatch can uh can get the
gps of
your location and um and they're gonna
have
law enforcement there as well they also
have laser-assisted targeting
you can protect yourself and your family
with taser's line of
smart self-defense products uh
i this is this is one of those sponsors
when they told me about it my first
question was
are we going to get we're going to get
the product i want to be able to you
know i want to i want to really be able
to give the endorsement on this
and um i was very excited to learn that
we will well we're going to be getting a
taser ourselves and
i think that'll be coming the next few
weeks if you want to get one
taser is available without a permit in
most u.s states
so you don't have to deal with a lot of
the red tape that you do uh with with
with other you know um
self-defense measures get the taser
pulse plus or taser strike light at
taser.com with promo code walsh you
could save 15
now at taser.com promo code walsh
spelled t-a-s-e-r
dot com promo code walsh restriction
supplies see site for details
all right next year number three here's
anna navarro on cnn
uh taking marco rubio to task for
getting a vaccine but there seems to be
a little bit of a disconnect here listen
i don't think they should include the
senators period
particularly listen there's something
that really gets stuck i think in my
crime in
other people's claw at the idea that
people who have been enabling
donald trump downplaying the covet virus
calling it
a hoax who have attended spoken at
encouraged promoted and participated and
so many of his
reckless rallies where people have been
packed like sardines
and have spoken at these rallies knowing
people are there masculists
who have attended super spreader events
at the white house
like we've seen you know so many people
get
infected with covet at them and then and
then
after they've been selfish after they've
been reckless after they've been
serviled to donald trump then they get
to
jump the line and go in front of people
who are in nursing homes
and go in front of people who've been
risking their lives for 10
months to keep others safe like medical
workers
they get to go in front of people who
are on dialysis and who are on chemo
give me a damn break
yeah it's it sounds like what she's
talking about here
is a political basically a political
test to decide who gets the vaccine
because she's not she's now it's one
thing if you're saying
well the lawmakers shouldn't be putting
themselves in front of the line to get
the vaccine i agree with that
except that the first person who you
should be blaming for that or yelling at
is alexandria casey or cortez because
she's the youngest
she went and got the vaccine yesterday
and had it on instagram
but that's not exactly what anna navarro
is talking about here on cnn
what she's saying is she starts by
saying oh you know the senators and he's
a lawmaker and he shouldn't
but then she gets into uh he's servile
to donald trump
you know he's he's going to rallies
so the fact that he's quote unquote
servile to donald trump that's the
reason he shouldn't be allowed to get
the vaccine
because he hasn't passed the political
litmus test that's what she's proposing
here a political litmus test
people have the right political views
they should be allowed to get vaccinated
pretty horrifying but it's what we come
to expect from uh from cnn
all right reading from the daily wire
actor eddie izzard
uh appearing on sky arts portrait artist
of the year
which is a competition series where
artists are challenged to create a
portrait of three famous subjects
uh it came out as a as a as a girl but
it was kind of interesting how he did i
think we have the audience
the audio is a little bit hard to
understand not the best audio quality
but let's uh let's listen to this
eddie you told us a little bit about
why you've done this can you elaborate
well i try to do things that i think are
interesting
and this is the first program i've asked
if i could read
she and her this little transition
period how does that feel
well it feels great because people
assume that or they just know me from
before but i'm gender fluid i just want
to be based in girl mode from now on
what if it feels right it's just gonna
make it positive and
i'm saying like it's just stuff so just
keep trying everything
one life live it well exactly
okay so eddie izzard he says um
he tries to do things that are
interesting
and so he's deci he's he's still gender
fluid
whatever the hell that means he's still
gender fluid
um but he wants to be based in girl mode
now
because that's interesting the first
thing here is that none of that means
anything
based in girl mode well i'm in my girl
mode
what does that mean but he wants to do
because it's interesting
it's just sort of it's it's an
interesting thing to do
and this plays into this uh i i think
highlights two points that i often make
about this
the first thing is okay eddie izzard is
wearing girl clothes and he puts on
lipstick
and then says i'm in girl mode now i'm
on you know i
wear lipstick and now i'm in girl mode
and
when you do that and when the left
celebrates it
they are only perpetuating and promoting
the very uh gender
you know paradigm that they're
supposedly trying to dismantle
because what is wearing lipstick and
wearing girl clothes what does it have
to do with being a girl
they would say it has absolutely nothing
to do with it
so now you wear lipstick and you're in
girl wearing lipstick puts you in girl
mode
that's supposed to be the that's
supposed to be exactly the paradigm the
dynamic um
that they're wanting to get rid of
and a lot of this transgenderism stuff
only promotes it
solidifies it as i talk about all the
time you know it's it's it's
uh for we we were always told
that well there's nothing in particular
feminine about wearing a dress
just because you wear a dress doesn't
mean you're feminine these are all
artificial constructs there's
there's no reality to them and now they
tell us a boy puts on a dress and he is
a girl
if a boy wants to wear a dress that's a
sign that actually not just that he
that he that he's girly but that he is a
girl
okay so you're you are reinforcing that
um
that dynamic that you were supposedly
trying to destroy so that's the first
thing
but then also you see this is just
narcissism
that's all this is it's not it's not
that hard to decipher
this is narcissism this is someone who's
extremely full of himself
and uh and he want he wants to be
interesting he wants to be more
interesting than just the normal plebes
who are happy to stick with normal
pronouns and to just be a
man or a woman no i'm i'm more
interesting than that i'm i'm a much
more complex individual
so i think it'd be interesting for me to
identify as gender fluid that's what
we're being told there
i want to take a second to tell you
about one of our uh sponsors on the show
neutral fall uh listen with with
nutrifall they are providing
you a solution to a problem that many
people suffer with
but you don't have to suffer with it
there is a solution to it and that's
hair loss
neutrophil is formulated with potent
botanicals to help you grow hair as
strong as you are and it's physician
formulated to be 100
drug free on top of that on top of
thicker stronger hair without laser
chemicals neutrophils ingredients
may also help you get a handle on better
sleep stress
stress response skin nails libido visit
nutrafall.com and take their hair
wellness quiz for customized product
recommendations that put the power to
grow thicker stronger hair
back into your hands it takes just a few
minutes to do and when you subscribe
you'll receive monthly deliveries so you
never miss a dose shipping is free and
you can pause or cancel anytime
does it work that's the big question
here yes in clinical studies neutral
fall uses
users saw thicker stronger hair growth
with less shedding
in three to six months um in these in
these clinical studies 72 percent of men
saw more scalp coverage and 86 of women
saw improved hair growth
after six months those are the studies
say whether you're experiencing thinning
or not you deserve hair as strong as you
are neutral fall can help you achieve
your best hair growth
instantly you can grow thicker healthier
hair
and support our show by going to
nutrafall.com and using promo code walsh
to get 20 percent off
this is their best offer available
anywhere you want to take advantage of
this
plus free shipping on every order get 20
off at nutrafall.com
promo code walsh their best offer
anywhere 20 off
at nutrafall.com spelled
n-u-t-r-a-f-o-l-dot-com promo code walsh
for hair as strong as you are finally
from nbc 12
governor ralph northam announced that
virginia's statue of confederate
general robert e lee was removed from
the u.s capitol overnight
a representative from the governor's
office was present for the removal
along with united states senator tim
kaine and congresswoman jennifer wexton
for 111 years the confederate statue has
stood along with america's first
president george washington
as virginia's contributions governor
northam said
we should all be proud of this important
step forward for our commonwealth and
our country
the confederacy is a symbol of
virginia's racist and divisive history
and it is past time we tell our story
with images of perseverance
diversity and inclusion
let me just say that first of all any
civilization
that puts forward diversity and
inclusion
at it as its highest virtues will die
you cannot base a civilization on that
because those are not
virtues at all diversity and inclusion
are not virtues
dignity courage selflessness
these are virtues and these are the
things that we should be
hailing these are the things we should
be celebrating
and men and women who exemplify those
virtues those are the ones who deserve
to have statues
i would say robert e lee
one thing i could tell you for sure
about robert e lee a lot more impressive
and a lot more of a
consequential of a man than ralph
northam
and i would also say a better if if i
was a virginian
i would rather i would say robbie lee is
a better representative of virginia than
ralph northam
ralph northam who remember um the man
who smeared shoe polish on his face
to dance around like michael jackson the
man who much
much worse even than that uh came out
and
talked about legalizing the abortion
of of of babies after birth
now he's worried now that robert e lee
is a problematic figure for virginia so
we've got to get rid of him
listen um
when this was announced yesterday of
course you know as always you know
the left celebrates it and says it's a
it's a great step forward and everything
and we expect that
but as always you know you see
conservatives who come out and defend it
as well
and say yeah i'm not i don't like
tearing down statues in general and
you know i don't think that we should be
taking abraham lincoln's name off of
schools this has happened
thomas jefferson i'm not into that but
uh but this i'm okay with
i i think this is reasonable this is
fine 111 year old statute's been there
ralph northam decides he doesn't like it
and so he's going to take it out i'm
fine with that
just realize if you're a conservative
and you're supporting this you
you you are you are supporting the exact
same logic
that leads to and is right now right now
as we're watching th
this is happening hand in hand with
abraham lincoln's name comes off the
school
you're supporting that same logic
the same thing is applied to
abraham lincoln george washington thomas
jefferson thomas jefferson
was a racist slave owner
he was no way around that
so if that's the reason for taking
robert e lee's statue down then it's
going to be applied to thomas jefferson
this really isn't that difficult to
understand
which is why as conservatives we should
be opposed to all of this
tearing down statues tearing down
statues in the name of diversity and
inclusion
we should never ever support that under
any circumstance i don't care who the
statue
is portraying this is something i
we really shouldn't even need to explain
one of the problems that we have as men
is we don't like going to the doctor
uh maybe we're embarrassed to go we
don't feel like going we come up with a
lot of excuses
for not going to the doctor well here's
a solution to that
for hims.com for hims.com for him.com is
all about men's wellness you need help
with
ed hair loss or have a cold whatever it
is if you're interested in mental health
or cova 19 home tests hymns is there for
you
through hymns you can get the
prescription medication that treats ed
this is real science
real solutions to ed hims makes it easy
hims connects you with a licensed
medical professional online who can
provide
fda-approved prescription medication to
treat aed
this would cost hundreds of bucks if you
had to go through a doctor or pharmacy
not so with hymns hymns makes it simple
and affordable no embarrassing
conversations no expensive appointments
just answer a few questions online
online about your medical history and a
provider will confidentially review it
if approved your medication is shipped
directly to your door in discrete
packaging and also shipping is free
so there's a lot of benefits you get no
more searching online for answers to
questions about ed or sexual wellness
just go to your him's account and ask a
medical professional that you can trust
so try hymns today by starting out with
a free online visit go to for hymns.com
matt for your free visit that's for
hims.com
f-o-r-h-i-m-s
dot com slash matt prescription products
are subject to medical provider approval
require an online consultation with a
medical provider who will determine if
prescription is appropriate
see website for full details and safety
information remember that's for hims.com
matt also um daily wires excited to
announce that the historical docu series
apollo 11 what we saw is now available
exclusively for daily wire members so
you don't want to miss this originally
released as an audio podcast for apple
and spotify what we saw takes a detailed
look
at the apollo 11 mission to land a man
on the moon it was the culmination of a
heated
decades-long space race between cold war
rivals the united
united states and soviet union and the
podcast explores one of america's
greatest accomplishments through the
eyes of
millions of americans who lived through
it now apollo 11 what we saw is
available to watch as well as listen
over at dailywire.com or on apple tv or
roku app
i did an interview with series writer
and host bill whittle while filling in
for ben's radio show you could take a
quick listen
to that right now bill thanks for being
with us
it's good to be here matt i'm sorry we
haven't had a chance to meet in person
but you do great work out there
i appreciate it thanks and and uh and
congratulations on the series i thought
it was great to
great listening to it it's even better
when you get when you get the full
visual experience
can you can you talk about maybe some of
the things that surprised you
as you were researching and preparing
for this series obviously it's a famous
story one that everyone feels like they
already know but as a viewer listener
there's so much that you get from a
series like this
that maybe you'd forgotten or you didn't
know did you have any sort of any sort
of wow moments when you were
getting ready for this well i've got
i've had like two different kinds of
well moments there were a number
of times during the course of i knew
this story really when we started
but as i started to drill down deeper
into it there was just every
you know every hour of research or stuff
i just i didn't know that
uh the one that stays in my mind just
off the top of my head
was that um on apollo 13 and 14
uh alan shepard was supposed to be
commanding apollo 13 and jim lovell was
supposed to be commanding apollo 14
but shepard uh was getting a little late
into his training so
lovell and shepard agreed to switch
which meant that jim lovell went on
apollo 13 which was of course the one
that
um had the explosion on the way to the
moon so if they hadn't done that switch
level would have walked on the moon he
was there uh twice
uh and those are the little things i
didn't know but but to be honest with
you
matt the the real payoff for me has been
the just the number of people that i've
heard from
uh who've said i used to believe in the
moon landing conspiracy and now i just
it just i just don't it just doesn't
hold any water anymore
one thing that concerns me maybe
depresses me
is that it seems your your generation
was the last to have this great
defining moment um a moment of triumph
and i think about my generation
we have defining moments but they're all
terrible 911 would be one
we're living through another one right
now uh what do you think about that
do you think that's that's true that
maybe that was the last sort of great
triumphant
moment where the whole world could come
together and and celebrate in that way
well i don't know the answer to that uh
certainly
like you looking around at what we see
going on now
sometimes i think that july 20th 1969
was
is going to be recorded as the jet that
was the pinnacle of human history that
was
as good as it got but then i saw the
spacex boosters landing and i saw and
continue to see what elon musk is doing
and and elon musk i think is going to be
able to pull this off
only because only because elon musk
owns that company does whatever he wants
with it all the initial the early
uh pioneers of aviation guys like
lockheed and boeing and then
cessna leer all of these guys were
individuals that ran their companies the
way they wanted them to
and since the apollo landings uh
companies like boeing and lockheed
have become these enormous bureaucracies
and they can't do anything right man
they can't their their vehicles don't
work they've already decided that one of
the vehicles that they've been working
on for 12 years now or something
they couldn't get the primary system to
work so they're going to fly with
band-aids and backups meanwhile elon
musk is out there with it with a
with a barge called of course i still
love you and
and when he when he let go of that tesla
roadster
and they started playing david bowie and
don't panic from hitchhiker's guide to
the galaxy
was on the navigation screen i said this
guy's going to pull it off because he
understands
the the fundamental thing about it is
that it needs to be new it needs to be
shocking
it needs to be cool and it needs to be
fun something to be proud of
and if this upcoming uh so-called
administration
if i don't want to call it that but in
any event
um if they leave him alone he's going to
get us to mars for sure
so this series is just one piece of all
the new content that we have coming down
the pipeline including a new show with
candace owens the entire prageru library
a new entertainment channel
a new investigative journalism team tons
of stuff coming up and you don't want to
miss any of it going into the new year
become a daily wire insider or above
member for 20
off with code watch over at
dailywire.com
subscribe and make sure to
that's downl subscribe to get 20 off
your membership
with codewatch and access to all of our
new and existing content
let's get now to our daily cancellation
[Music]
today for our daily cancellation on this
uh final show of the year 2020 for me
anyway
i'm gonna potentially maybe cancel
myself
it would be a fittingly tragic way to
end the year um
there may even be some poetic justice in
it for me to fall in the end on my own
cancellation sword
but i'm not sure yet if i'm canceled i
figure what what i what i would do today
is go back
and do sort of a year in review of my
own show
based on media matters hit pieces so i
went to google
looked up the articles that that have
appeared on media matters website
about things that i've said on this show
over the past year these are
we can assume the most offensive and
outrageous and objectionable things
i've said the things that earned me a
patented media matters rebuke
so now i'm going to go over them review
these offensive comments and decide
if i should be canceled for my sins so i
i hope first of all that you appreciate
the great
bravery that's required for me to expose
myself to you
in this way not in a jeffrey toobin sort
of way but in a spiritual sense
this is accountability and transparency
and perhaps in the end repentance so
let's take a look um these won't be
exactly in chronological order and we
can't go through all the articles as
there are quite a few
on media matters about the daily wire
and about all the hosts including myself
but let's review the top three okay and
we'll we'll see if i
if i need to apologize and be and be
canceled at the end of the year here
first we have a media matters article
from march 3rd 2020
headline daily wire host calls for
extreme measures including violence
against drag queens
and then i'm quoted in the subheading
quote real men should be grabbing that
drag queen by the collar and kicking him
out on his ass
the article says the daily wires matt
walsh and michael knowles called for
drastic measures to prevent drag queens
for being around children
with walsh explicitly calling for
violence against them by saying real men
should kick a drag queen
out on his ass and call the police
walsh also said that the adults in a
room in which a drag queen danced in
front of a child should be going to
prison
and knowles called on the arm of the
state to stop this
the daily wires official youtube account
uploaded video of matt walsh's
extreme comments made during the matt
wall show podcast which has received
more than 31 000 views
the video cuts off before walsh's
explicit calls for violence but includes
his claim that the adult should be
arrested for letting a drag queen
perform in front of a child okay
am i canceled for this verdict no
i'm not in fact i was quite profoundly
correct in everything i just said
and everything i said that was
documented there drag queen story hour
should be illegal and men should not be
allowed to perform in drag for children
this is basic common sense
the kind of thing that people would have
stared at you in confusion if you had
said it out loud at any point in history
up until like last tuesday
they wouldn't understand understood why
you felt the need to actually say out
loud
that drag queens shouldn't be performing
for children at the library
so i can't be canceled for this though i
can't speak for knowles
nor can i defend his shameful bigotry
second article from february 24th 25th
headline
daily wires matt walsh melts down about
pedophilia because
pete buttige helped the kid come out
oh you wouldn't want to melt down about
pedophilia apparently
and then i'm quoted quote creepy pete
and other forces of evil will eventually
be arguing in favor of legalizing
pedophilia
the article says after openly gay
presidential candidate pete boonij
helped the child
come out as gay the daily wires matt
walsh freaked out that progressives will
legalize pedophilia claiming
quote i could predict that nearly every
leftist who today is arguing that
three-year-olds can choose their gender
will eventually be arguing in favor of
legalizing pedophilia
on february 22nd the nine-year-old asked
buddhija to
help me tell the world i'm gay at a
campaign rally walsh responded by
calling him
creepy pete going on a rant about child
sex and pedophilia
and claiming bootage was exploiting a
child's emotional confusion
walsh's claim that lgbtq allies will
eventually be advocating for pedophilia
as patently false and part of a
right-wing smear
that often targets drag queens and trans
youth
all right verdict not cancelled
unfortunately it turns out that i'm once
again completely correct it is it is
not pete budage's job to help a kid come
out of the closet
and the sexualization of children
happening on the left
does put us on a slippery slope to the
normalization of pedophilia
absolutely third finally from october
7th headline daily wire host says it's
treasonous for stupid people to vote
here they present just the video clip
which i guess is supposed to be so
horrifying that it speaks for itself we
don't need to play the video kept
the clip the quote is accurate you know
there doesn't need to be any more
context than that
i did argue that stupid people should be
legally prevented from voting
and i did say that a stupid person who
chooses to vote is doing such harm to
the country that you could almost
consider it treason
verdict on this um i gotta say not
cancelled
if anything i should get a medal for
being so right about
everything you just heard there and
that's the main thing that i think when
i look back on these moments uh that
media matters is highlighted
i'm frankly stunned and inspired by my
own
rightness um i'm in all of the fact that
i have managed to be so correct so often
you know i i really did intend to
acknowledge and make amends for the
wrongs i'd committed
and uh and to take take my cancellation
like a man
but it turns out i'm not eligible to be
canceled this year
i have cancelled my wife
multiple times my kids dogs cats
birthdays christmas trees
biden trump phone calls hallways canada
australia
100 other things but i cannot join them
in their cancellation
not this year anyway maybe next
and so to all of you who also survived
the year without being canceled all five
or six of you
congratulations we are the few the
chosen the survivors
and to you and myself i say
congratulations
and merry christmas and happy new year
to the rest of you i say how dare you do
better
do better next year and we'll leave it
there
for the day and the year i'll talk to
you in 2021
godspeed
the matte wall show is produced by sean
hampton executive producer jeremy boring
our supervising producers are mathis
glover and robert sterling
our technical director is austin stevens
production manager pablo wadowski
the show is edited by danny d'amico our
audio is mixed by mike coromina
hair makeup is done by nika geneva and
production assistant mckenna waters
the matte wall show is a daily wire
production copyright daily wire 20 20.
congress passes an insulting relief bill
a prominent commentator suggests
republicans should not receive the
vaccine
and eddie izzard becomes a chick check
it out on the michael knoll show